Dude Perfect having called the migrant
crisis an invasion this was the Home
Secretary doubling down traveling to
Kent by Chinook helicopter but this time
not coming out fighting she kept her
distance from the cameras during her
visit to the overcrowded Immigration
Center at manston careful to avoid
journalists questions but questions
persist into a system she herself has
described as broken especially after
this
the footage shows a group of migrants
who had been taken from manston on
Tuesday night only to be left stranded
in central London they were mistakenly
dropped off at Victoria Coach Station
with nowhere to go after being helped by
a homeless charity they were eventually
taken to a hotel in Norwich we found
that hotel and one of those who was
stranded hazibullah from Afghanistan
when we reached the London the driver
tell us you go out time we don't know
where we go where did they say you were
going
not not real but not the last so he got
on the bus from manston but you didn't
know where you were going yeah yeah
he says there were 11 of them in all but
officials at the hotel prevented us from
approaching them still important
properties there so I'm gonna have to
ask you just to remove yourself from
private property the Asylum Seekers we
have managed to briefly speak with here
say they've been told by security guards
not to chat to the media and that if
they do the home office will be told in
actual fact though whilst they're being
housed here the Asylum Seekers are free
to come and go as they please and speak
with whomever they like
the home office said it only releases
Asylum Seekers from manston if they say
they have somewhere to stay and that
they worked at PACE to find this group
accommodation once they knew what had
happened but the incident has prompted
yet more criticism of the situation at
manston even coming from within the home
secretary's own party
there are children there who have been
detained for in some cases it seems as
as much as a month that's wholly
unacceptable but it's also unlawful and
my question to the home office include
on what basis are you detaining people
what concerns do you have about the the
vulnerabilities to judicial review is
the taxpayer going to be exposed to yet
more costs are you concerned about the
conditions at manston Home Secretary are
the conditions in Manson inhumane
arriving back from Kent Sue Ella
Braverman once again avoided questions
but this is a crisis she's unable to
escape Ivor Bennett Sky News Norwich